thanks welcome back from
lunch so Twitter is uh really one of the
Prime franchises of uh the internet how
many people I out of curiosity here uh
use Twitter regularly all the hands went
up of course Dick's are happy for that
but you know for something so simple uh
just posting a message of no more than
the famous 140 characters I I find it's
actually incredibly nuanced and uh you
know and even though we have our comfort
zones with Twitter there's probably a
lot that we don't know about it from a
us should standpoint uh a business
standpoint and a cultural standpoint but
fortunately who better do we have uh to
illuminate these matters and de Costo
the uh CEO of Twitter uh previously he
founded feed burner a couple other
companies uh was a Google went to
Twitter in 2009 became the CEO in 2010
um and before he was an internet Mogul
uh he was an improv comic but we did
resist the temptation to set up the
stage like a taxi cab headed to the
hospital yes thank you for you know uh
instead we're going to talk about uh
Twitter and when we're done uh you'll
have your your chance to ask questions
and of course of course we'll take
questions from Twitter so deck you've
been the CEO for a year and a half now
what's different now in Twitter than it
was when you got there um it's a funny
thing you know there are there are
elements of the culture that you want to
retain as you grow from a a 50 person
company when I got there as coo in in
the fall of 2009 to a thousand person
company that we are now you want to make
sure that the culture uh that existed
that got the company to where it with is
where where it is is retained and then
there are obviously um elements of the
company that you have to change when
you're in hypergrowth mode you need
Executives who can scale uh you need to
make sure your managers are managing
consistently Etc so I'll give you a
couple examples of what's changed uh one
of the things I noticed when I took over
as CEO was that because we were growing
so fast we had managers coming in from
places like Google and eBay and all over
all over the valley and we were also
promoting Managers from within who were
new managers and first-time managers and
I realized that all my managers were
managing differently you had people from
the companies they came from that were
managing maybe based on the way they
were told to or learn to manage at this
other company and then new managers who
were making it up as they went along uh
so one of the things that I did was I
created a managing a Twitter course that
I teach personally and it's about a 5H
hour course to all of our managers to
make sure everyone is managing in a
consistent fashion so it's been largely
um things like that scaling an operation
I would say if I wanted to think about
another axis uh in a different way about
things I've changed it's been
about organizational Clarity and trying
to organize the company in a way that
allows us to build and deliver product
more efficiently you and I talked about
that a little bit backstage um combining
for example the design practice and the
application engineering practice under a
single executive so that neither was
subservient to the other some
organizations uh the engineers Define
how to build a solution and they make
some crude mocks and then hand it to
design and say make that look pretty at
the end and in other organizations you
see the opposite the designers build a
beautiful Mock and then hand it to the
engineers and say it should work like
that right uh and I wanted to make sure
that these two functions were working
together and jointly defining how
Solutions were shaped and created from
the bottom up uh from the get-go and so
that's one of the things I did right
well one of the things that that you did
uh as a CEO is you brought back the
founder yes of Twitter Jack dorsy um
who's known for his design sense what
was his participation in in that
initiative you know
so uh you mentioned earlier I I I
started or I co-founded and ran three
consumer internet companies before
coming to Twitter and so I think I think
I have a a real appreciation for the for
the importance of the voice of the
inventor of the product you know when
Biz Evan Jack founded the
company uh they had a very real sense of
what they wanted the voice of the
product to be so I brought Jack back
because I wanted to make sure that the
voice of the inventor was incorporated
into how the product evolved and I think
because that I because of having that
background um it's very easy for Jack
and I to work together and I Look to Him
uh to help shape the direction of the
product um now I think uh every three
days there's a billion tweets is that
right yes it's it's a little less than
every three days now but that's correct
it took three years for the first
billion to be sent and now a billion are
sent every two and a half days or so so
H how what are these tweets how is this
being used what can you tell me about
the the behavior of Twitter users like
uh how many people does the average
Twitter user follow how many people
follow him or her give give me a little
you know uh background on what's going
on uh behind this you know third of a
billion everyday tweet stream yeah sure
so I'll answer the question in the
context of the way we talk about our
vision for the company so our vision for
the company is Twitter brings you closer
and our that's our vision for a few
reasons over the course of the last
couple years as all these stories pour
into the company about the different
ways people use
Twitter whether it's the Colorado
Rockies pitcher who ask a question on
Twitter that hey I need to warm up is
there anyone near the K field that can
come to the stadium and thow play catch
with me and this guy who just got the
news earlier in the day that was
completely clear of cancer that he'd had
for many years uh you know grabs his
Mitten tweets to the pitcher hey I'm I
can be at the stadium in 10 minutes and
he goes there and they play catch and
now they're like good friends there's an
awesome column by Rick Riley si.com
about that yeah whether whether it's
that or you know this email you get from
this guy in Tunisia uh his uh Twitter ID
is Slim 404 who's describing the role
that social media played in the context
of organizing protests there or all
sorts of these stories and they're all
completely different the thing that ties
them all together is this context for uh
whether it's bringing you closer to a
hero or a friend or the rest of the
world um the thing that sh the common
shape to all these different stories was
Twitter brings you closer um and we left
the end of the sentence open because our
users have always always completed our
sentences for us so Twitter I can't say
that's correct and that's why that's why
that's our vision for Twitter and that's
why we don't finish the sentence
ourselves because our users will shape
the end of the
sentence but you know uh I think it's
interesting some you show Twitter to to
to someone and you know and you feel oh
just pick it up right away but they're
they're confused they don't know where
to go they don't know how to start uh
there seems to be a hurdle and they say
GE I don't I don't really want to talk
about the sandwich I'm eating that seems
to be the the cliche about it yeah so
how do you cope with that so here's how
we think about that um It's a
combination of a challenge around all
this content flooding into the platform
now more and more every day and the
classic onboarding challenge we've
always had a Twitter of this gap between
awareness of Twitter and engagement on
Twitter um and the way we're looking to
address that is through Discovery and we
just made an announcement I think
probably half an hour ago or a few
minutes ago around an upgrade to our
hashtag discover portion of the UI we'll
continue to invest a ton of effort on
that because what's that new thing sure
so hashd discover is the our opportunity
to help you understand what's happening
on Twitter right now that's relevant to
you it's on top of your timeline or any
accounts you're following it's based on
what we think your interests are this is
what we think is most relevant to you on
Twitter happening right now and we need
to make that super simple and dead easy
for both our existing users and the very
first time you come to Twitter to get
you into the platform and into
meaningful content right away so you'll
continue to see us iterate on that and
make a number of announcements around
that this year how much do you know
about what I'm interested in you know
that you could serve these relevant uh
you know uh tweets that I can discover
sure so today uh the answer to that is
based on who you follow your follow the
accounts you follow paint a picture of
what we call your interest graph right I
follow San Francisco Giants and a bunch
of University of Michigan football
players and on and on and on and you
sooner or later get a pretty nice
picture of me as I am interested in
University of Michigan I'm in I'm what
geography don't you know that too sure
you start what yeah of course we know we
know geography but you I think more
interestingly we get a picture of your
interests and that interest graph shapes
a maybe even more compelling picture of
who you are and what you're interested
in then than you know gender age
location Etc so let's talk about the
business sure of of Twitter here I think
I I saw an estimate you know um and I'm
I'm sure you're probably aren't going to
confirm or deny this but might but tell
me if it's crazy that this year you're
on track for um a little over you know
uh a quarter of a billion in in in in
Revenue there uh I don't know if you
want to stipulate that or not but you
know it it's something there and that
comes mostly from ads your money comes
mostly from ads correct yes and you and
the main part of your ads are are these
promoted tweets is that correct yeah
could you explain how that works it's
not just someone says you know I'm going
to buy a tweet and and and there it is a
little more complicated than that isn't
it yeah so maybe the way I'll well sure
the short answer is yes I'll explain how
it works um and I'll do so in the
context of defining kind of how we build
at Twitter so forth so um we had a sense
that the way we wanted to monetize the
platform because tweets went out to all
these different places from the least
expensive phones with the most primitive
uis over text messages to the most
beautiful interfaces on the most
sophisticated devices in the world and
we knew all that would evolve we knew
that we needed a monetization model that
went wherever the tweets went M um the
simplest answer to that was well the
monetization the unit of mon ization has
to be the Tweet because the atomic unit
of everything in Twitter is the Tweet so
uh that's where we started we said well
okay the unit of monetization will be
the Tweet so the tweets will be the ads
themselves the second part that we and
we was we is me and the leadership team
the second part that we defined was uh
the ads have to be initially organic
content on the platform so and one of
the ways we'll be resilient to spammy
ads is in order for a tweet to become an
ad it has to First go out organically to
its followers and therefore companies
will be less motivated to go create
these these things that are just ads
that annoy people because they will be
going out organically to their followers
first and you won't want to risk losing
followers at the expense of this uh
meaningless ad um that was what we set
out as Direction at the sort of the
leadership top down from the company and
we gave that to the design and
engineering team and said go Define how
you implement that and then they Define
the solution bottom up and that solution
was okay here's how we'll do that uh
here's how we'll inject those into the
timeline this is when we'll start to
roll them on a mobile etc etc and you
know do you find that you know it seems
to me that some aspects are sort of like
the the Google AdWords like the
advertisers won't pay unless you know uh
people actually respond to yes
advertisers only pay when people engage
with the Tweet so they reply to it they
retweet it they click on it right but
even you know uh a quarter of a billion
dollars that's not an AdWords rocket
ship takeoff there do you feel that
you're going to need something else you
know to to add to this or can this grow
into the kind of thing which is this
organic money machine like you see
Google have and now Facebook says that
they're confident their model is like
that yeah the short answer to the
question is yeah we're confident that
we've got a hit on our hands and that
this business will be a really big
business I'm never going to optimize for
short-term Revenue at the expense of
either the user experience or the
longevity of the platform and the
company and if people think we're going
about it too cautiously they can go
ahead and think that and I don't really
care uh the business is working well say
what they won't invest in your IPO right
they can they can they can stay on the
sidelines as they have an opportunity to
not stay on the sidelines yeah speaking
of which I know you're you put a date to
it but what is your thinking you in this
pretty heated era now with some of these
you know other big pillars of the
internet uh go going public what's just
general thinking about that so I kind of
just answered the question but I'll but
I'll be more specific I'm a little dense
yeah no that's all right I am too um the
business is working so well and we
Finance the growth of the company the
way we wanted to finance it last year um
that we don't see any need or urgency to
even start think thinking about that
stuff you know you you you IPO because
you want to finance the growth of the
business and our business is growing on
its own organically and we've got plenty
of money in the bank from the financing
the private financings we did last year
so when you know I look at the things I
think about on a day-to-day basis and
the challenges and where we're going in
the next X months or years that's not
something I worry about or think about
and so then the idea of this you know uh
environment the idea I know you've
pushed back against the idea there's
some window that you know is open now
because everything's very heated in in
this field yeah I think that's
um silly and shortsighted thinking um
you know Google went public when they
wanted to on their own terms if you have
a great business right and that business
is growing in a way that is satisfying
to you and makes sense and is consistent
with your projections then you can be a
public company whenever you want to be a
public company you're not beholden to
some window of opportunity where the
Market's hot right now and etc etc I
think that's short-term thinking and
hopefully we don't have to approach
things that way um speaking of you know
maybe you can comment just on the
industry in general you know Mark
andreon earlier today uh was you know uh
dashed you know the idea from his point
of view that we're in any kind of bubble
there um you know we've had this
Instagram thing there's matter of fact
uh you know there's even some talk that
Twitter wanted uh by Instagram obviously
not for not for a billion dollars uh but
you know are are we in a bubble are are
things heated now that you might see
opportunities for Acquisitions that you
can't get because they're they're valued
so
highly I don't know I don't I don't
really pay any attention to that stuff
so I mean my Frank answer I don't I you
know I could sit here and give you a a
yes or no answer yes we're in a bubble
no we're not in a bubble I don't really
know and I don't really care um I don't
think about the things I I do in that
context I mean I just don't so and that
wouldn't inform any decision I made
really based on whether I thought we
were or weren't in a bubble I mean sure
you make decisions about Acquisitions or
financings based on whether you think
you know your stock is cheap or your
stock is expensive or so forth but since
we don't need to worry about financings
uh right now I'm not worried about that
so let me let me change the subject it's
uh it's Mayday today um and you know
Twitter has been Associated and uh I
think to its credit you know Twitter's
stood up for this with free speech yeah
and being enabling technology to people
to express themselves there talk a bit
how how you walk that line there with
being a a company which uh encourages
its users to be active politically yet
not be identified with a political view
of
yourselves um
so I'll answer that in the context of
the vision Twitter brings you closer
okay and maybe I'll tell the the story
that I told um gosh over a year ago at
Mobile World Congress in Barcelona I
point with my thumb this way as if
Barcelona's that way I have no idea
where it is uh this is the universal
signal for Barcelona yeah um I can see
Barcelona my Miranda I probably some
offensive gesture in Basque country and
I've just annoyed you know all sorts of
people
across across the world anyway um so so
uh there's this this Chinese artist I
wewe who designed the Beautiful You Know
Birds Nest stadium and Olympic stadium
in Beijing and um he created this
installation um that was at the tapate
museum in London uh a while back and the
installation was these hundreds of
thousands of of ceramic hand paint
pained sunflower
seeds and from As you stood back from
the room it looked like this sea of just
stones that were black stones that were
spread across the floor and of course
you couldn't tell really what they were
as you got closer it looks like you can
start to tell oh it looks like they've
Stamped Out hundreds of thousands of
sunflower seeds and spread them across
the floor but as you picked them up you
started to realize that they were all
individually shaped and painted
differently and youi and beautiful and
distinct in their own right
so that's what we want to bring to what
we're building the ability to shrink the
world and allow everybody to see each
other so in the context of political
speech for example the consequences of
our vision for Twitter brings you closer
mean that we will always allow
pseudonyms on the platform because
there're are country countes in which
political speech is restricted and if
political speech is restricted and you
can't speak freely then it's impossible
to see up close that there are others
who feel the way you do in these
particular countries and it has all
sorts of sort of secondary and tertiary
implications for the way we think about
the product and the future of the
product and we'll always we'll always
grow the business in that way it means
for example that we
won't make sacrifices to that way of
thinking
in order to enter a country in which
we're blocked right uh like like Iran
for example M well uh currently I know
that that uh Twitter as a company was
against soapa though you didn't block
yourselves out you thought wasn't the
way to go what about uh sispa the the
new law which essentially would say to a
company like Twitter that you know hey
there's no penalty for you if we just
happen to ask you for the data about
your users you can just give it to us no
problem problems you like there how do
you view that potential law which hasn't
been passed yet yeah so I'm just
starting to come up to speed on sispa
specifically so I don't have a specific
uh uh personal opinion on that piece of
legislation yet as I think you know and
I said before we thought soapa and Pippa
were extremely flawed legislation that
was crafted without the input of both
sides look I have
every understanding that content owners
need their intellectual property
protected I get that uh we thought that
if the legislation had been crafted with
both sides providing input to it you'd
have a much more elegant solution flawed
legislation ends up in the courts so
which is the reason we oppos that
previous legislation okay so I'll have a
couple more questions for uh we we open
it up one is you know Twitter really is
at the Forefront uh Forefront of the
second screen movement there and you
know anyone who you know at Twitter
stream of any proportion knows during
the gramys or uh you know any big event
you know someone dies pal everything
just you know uh explodes on there um
how do you augment that A and B do you
want to be on the first screen do you
are you developing deals that during uh
the Academy Awards or some other Super
Bowl or some other big event you would
actually have your stream and you know
you you determine what the mo the best
top tweets are you know uh flowing down
underneath
so uh the answer to your first question
is yeah Twitter has become the second
screen and and and maybe you could even
broaden that to say not just for as you
as you mentioned not just for televised
events but for any event when events
happen in the real world they happen
digitally on Twitter so a lot of the
work that we're going to be doing over
the course of this year you will see
drive toward tying that feedback loop of
the real world experience to the shared
experience on Twitter and bundling those
two more closely together I don't think
that the implications of that are oh
Twitter is on the first screen I think
that the implications of it are that the
shared experience on Twitter is a more
frictionless way to jump back and forth
between the two things as opposed to
putting this thing and smashing it onto
that screen so for example that means
being I just I'll give you one simple
example being sensitive to if tweets are
coming from the Kodak Theater during the
Oscars we can be pretty certain that
they're associated with hash Oscars and
we should incorporate those tweets into
that event shared experience on Twitter
so you'll see all sorts of those kinds
of things okay so we're going to shift
the questions I'm going to start by uh
taking a a Twitter question someone
asked uh can Twitter quantify a
sentiment metrics um now I know that
that this can be done you know is this
the kind of thing that you're interested
how do you know it can be done no I
don't know you said I know it can be
done well because I just happen to do a
story in the current initiative of wired
with a couple companies that are
actually doing this there you go and
creating news articles based on it so I
was just curious you don't get get it
defensive there's just wanted to know
how I it's a chance to plug the current
ini wir I'm not did you see how we did
that it was very seamlessly done perfect
perfect but are you going to do it no
we're we're not going to do that
ourselves uh we will look to the
ecosystem and third parties to provide
sentiment analysis there are lots of
specific int intricacies to sentiment
analysis on Twitter um specifically
Twitter is uh people love to be ironic
on Twitter it's a particularly well
suited to 140 characters and irony turns
out to be something that's difficult to
extract in sentiment analysis right my
experience yeah it's also difficult to
convince all your followers that you
actually are being
ironic right right maybe difficult for
both the computers and and your
followers to extract um so we're going
to let third parties who are who are
sophisticated and spend all their time
doing that to keep doing that okay all
right so questions U out
here U okay back up there Ellie Langer
CNBC social media Eli from
Brooklyn um similar to how we see brands
have the ability to pin tweets go into
the analytics will we ever see a pro
user an individual being a pro user and
if a user can actually pay to become a
pro user and have access to such
benefits um I think that's a perfectly
reasonable expectation that don't take
that at write down I know people write
down users will soon have the it's a
perfectly reasonable expectation we're
absolutely going to evolve the profiles
page to provide users with more
lightweight controls over that page and
that's the kind of thing that I would
like to see in that kind of environment
um but again the way we like to operate
is the leadership team you know that's
me that's my all of my engineering VPS
my design VP Jack Etc setting direction
right we want lightweight controls for
users in the profile page around these
kinds of things and then the designers
and Engineers work together to Define
how that will work so I don't know what
that will particularly look like when it
surfaces but it's that kind of thing yes
so um there's a another Twitter one
which actually is is something I like to
hear again uh will tweets again return
in realtime Fashion on Google searches
and as background to this uh last summer
your fire contract you know with Google
for them to get the fire hose of of
tweets uh so they could include it in
their real-time search the way they
wanted to do it ended and you know uh
currently uh Google's been complaining
that they don't have access to tweets uh
I know that you folks have come back and
saying you know they they have plenty of
access um but in any case uh we're not
getting the quality of tweets searched
on Google that that that we used to have
there um what's the situation are we
going to ever going to get it so Google
has as as as we've said a tremendous
access to the tweets through go Google
their their sophisticated crawler which
crawls us at a fairly extraordinary rate
um uh we continue to talk to Google uh
frequently and on an ongoing basis about
the relationship between the companies
they are a company that is doing several
different things right now um so those
conversations are more complicated than
they than they are with other companies
and we just have to see mean you feel
that go+ is like competing against you
so you're less likely to make a deal I'm
saying that they're doing they do
several different things so those
conversations have a complexity to them
that is different than our conversations
with other companies yeah but you've had
a great experience with apple deeply
integrating
Twitter into yeah it's platform right
right right so you know wouldn't you you
see something similar happen with with a
that deep Google integration there I'm
GNA say the same thing and I'll rephrase
it a third
way I'm not that dense I I'll go to a
different
question okay wait wait for the mic
please is it coming maybe you should
just shout it out uh yes so I was
wondering um what you think about people
self-advertising on Twitter uh and by
that I mean for instance Paris Hilton uh
sells tweets for a few thousand dollars
and she Stars the end of the message
with ad so so what do you think about
people taking it into their own
hands so I think what you're asking is
people who have got some Rel let's let
me just make sure I understand what
you're saying people who have got some
relationship with some third party and
then irrespective of doing anything with
us they tweet out something on behalf of
this third party relationship and they
just make it an ad in Twitter is that
what you're asking about yeah so
look people so this in fact this goes
directly to a court case that I was not
particularly well not happy at all with
the the finding on recently we say in
our terms of service very clearly users
own their own
tweets period right so if that's what
people want to do with their tweets they
can go ahead and do that and we're not
going to say you know users own their
own tweets except if they have a
relationship with some third party etc
etc so if if people want to go do that
then they can do that and if that's uh
if their followers respect that then
that's
great okay now up here the second
row this is about um Lori Fina again um
this is a question about the internet of
things and things tweeting I
specifically um had a project where my
daughter was having a pill minder tweet
and uh Twitter shut it down because I
didn't realize this um but if you tweet
the same thing over and over it's a spam
filter um but how in the future are you
looking at the internet of things and
how Twitter becomes a channel for things
to communicate with people bringing
people closer to their things
that was I obviously would need to work
work the word things into my response um
so uh first of
all first of all um the fact that that
was uh uh suspended for spam signals an
unfortunate consequence of some of our
early um preventative measures against
spam so that's unfortunate um it's
absolutely the case that there are more
and more things that are tweeting um I
expect that to continue it's a in many
cases you know you just gave a great
health example there are lots of other
emergency relief examples um in Japan
after the earthquake and ensuing tsunami
uh the re the nuclear reactor obviously
not the reactor itself unless it unless
the fusion got so hot that it became
sensient um the the nuclear reactor was
that was a horrible nuclear energy joke
um the re reactor had a Twitter account
that was tweeting its radiation levels
right um so people could be informed
about local safety and so on and so
forth um people have weight scales that
tweet their weight for toward goals and
on and on that's going to be more and
more a part of the world we live in and
we have to make sure that the way we
think about all sorts of things like
rate limits and spam signal and
everything else incorporate uh those
kinds of ideas in that future it's
happening more and more okay uh back
there
hi Rich Greenfield from bti you know
dick you made the comment before that
the second screen not just for TV events
but for all events but what's what's
interesting is a lot of Brands and a lot
of media sources are basically using
Twitter for free meaning they're putting
hashtags on TV um they're getting all
the benefits of using the Twitter
ecosystem but they're actually not
spending money per se from an
advertising or marketing standpoint is
that good is that bad and how do you
kind of build a business off of a lot of
this kind of usage of the Twitter
ecosystem it's great it's fantastic look
I appreciate everyone's you know concern
for our
business but but it's working
phenomenally well like when I go to when
when we worry when I go to bed at night
the thing I don't worry about is oh no
the business you know wor about people
asking you about the business I think
about things like you know pace of
execution and Cadence and are we too
design heavy in this in right now are we
too engineering heavy and how do we how
do we remove bureaucracy from our
developers ability to innovate and those
kinds of things are the things I worry
about now the business is working great
all of that stuff is a sign of a super
healthy ecosystem and a symbiotic
relationship between the producer of the
television show The Outdoor Concert
Coachella laa ploa Etc and this platform
so those things are great we look for
more of those and I'm delighted when I
see them and we'll we'll make plenty of
money on our own doing our other things
well I'm happy to hear that and I want
to thank you for coming by thanks for
having
me